hello class of 2015 welcome to Emory
this is Emily and this is Tanya and
together we're responsible for
orientation in the next few minutes
we'll give you some information about
what to expect before you come to Emory
as well as insights orientation week if
you're watching this video maybe you
found us on blackboard if you're
watching it on YouTube then head over
the classes at Emory edu and log in
using your Emory ID and password over
the course of the summer will be
releasing lots of information on
blackboard in two different horses from
religious life to athletics student
leadership opportunities to volunteering
we've got it all we'll help you learn
how to get involved in orientation 101
and if it's academic for majors and
minors to general education requirements
and the honor code will cover it all in
pace 101 you can expect to see new
material on blackboard at least once a
week and for the first time this summer
will be offering a series of webinars on
topic the students ask the most
questions about take advantage of these
resources they'll greatly help in your
transition to Emory and you'll feel
completely ready to join us for
orientation in August and speaking of
when you get here we have nearly 100
orientation leaders trained and excited
to meet you these students will serve as
your guides during orientation week
you'll be able to answer a fine answer
four questions that you have about Emory
campus and everything you need to know
about starting college after this video
there's a welcome message from the
orientation captains and they'll tell
you in their own words their experiences
at Emory and just how excited they are
to meet you so between now and August
here's what we want you to do check your
emails regularly log on to blackboard
regularly and complete the task that
appear take part in webinar series check
out the orientation website at college
MRA edu slash orientation foul and rain
orientation on twitter and if you have
any other questions feel free to drop us
an email at ec orientation at learn link
emory edu
finally get excited orientation has
consistently rated some of the best days
in s college students career we're
really looking forward to seeing you in
August until then have a great summer